so we're tracking a whole bunch of
vaccine trials and development for
coronavirus vaccines and there's news
from a couple of different vaccine
manufacturers or researchers that I
think is relevant important and
potentially optimistic which think oh we
could use a little bit of right now so
the first one is Oxford University
Oxford University could have a vaccine
ready to be used in September the reason
that Oxford has a head start is that
they've already been working on a
vaccine for prior coronaviruses and they
already have proven the the formula so
to speak to be harmless to humans from a
safety perspective so Oxford already has
a vaccine for this specific coronavirus
last month in a lab in Montana they
tested this specific vaccine on rhesus
monkeys they give the monkeys the
vaccine they exposed the monkeys to huge
amounts of the virus
the monkeys without the vaccine all got
the virus and more than 28 days later
the six monkeys that had been vaccinated
did not get the virus at any point in
time that's huge the rhesus monkey is
the closest thing to Homo sapiens for
the purposes of testing vaccines you can
read a lot about that if that's
interesting to you now is it guaranteed
that a vaccine that is safe in humans
and works in rhesus monkeys will work
just as well to create immunity in
humans no it's not a guarantee but it's
a very good sign
next step is human trials of this
specific vaccine they're going to be
doing a trial with 6,000 people by the
end of May that's very very big and will
be really important to see how that goes
now the question is does it work to
prevent corona virus in humans that's
what this 6,000 person test is meant to
figure out and a few important things
here to think about number one okay how
does a vaccine work the vaccine contains
an element of the germ that makes people
sick it could be a killed or
a conversion of the germ so that the
vaccine doesn't give you the disease
that would be a disaster some vaccines
have just part of the germ
it's enough of the germ the idea is
whether it's been weakened or it's only
a part of it or it's dead germ
it's got to be enough that the body
reacts by making antibodies which then
in an ideal world makes you immune to
the full germ if you were to be invaded
by it and you have to go through
numerous steps including testing the
vaccines for safety testing the vaccine
for efficacy seeing if it generates what
is the right dose to generate enough
antibodies that you will be immune you
can have a situation where the vaccine
is safe in the sense that it doesn't
harm humans but it might not make you
immune there can be cases where the
vaccine could make you have a more
serious version of the disease if you
were to be infected that would be a
disaster of course so what needs to
happen for this vaccine to be usable in
September first you've got to test the
6,000 humans in May that has to go well
number two there often is a production
issue when it comes to vaccines because
if you wait until you know it's the
vaccine to use to start production
you're behind and you've lost a really
important time that could be used to
start vaccinating people so what they're
going to do is now or soon they will
start production of this vaccine before
they even know for sure that it's going
to be the vaccine this is to be able to
have at least some millions of doses
ready as soon as it's determined that
this is a vaccine that works and then
lastly important if it were to be
available in September it's not going to
be everybody and their mother goes and
gets this vaccine in September if
everything goes perfectly in September
there would be a few million doses it
would probably be authorized under
emergency use and probably at that stage
it would just be for health care health
care workers which makes sense and then
subsequently for the most vulnerable
people in populations so this is all
good news but most likely there will be
more than one
vaccine that's used when things get
going because of the number of doses
globally that are going to be needed so
a couple of questions that now come up
will this be like a flu vaccine that's
only effective against like that year's
strain or mutation answer we don't know
there's a research paper that says that
the vaccine candidates for this corona
virus would match all circulating
strains of the virus but not that they
would work on all corona viruses that's
an important distinction there would be
of the vaccines being worked on now we
already have at least moderately
different strains of this corona virus
that have spread due to mutation the
vaccine would likely work on all of
those but that would not work on any
corona virus as you know there are many
corona viruses including common colds
can sometimes be caused by corona
viruses the good news is that kovat 19
seems more stable than the flu virus the
mutation rate is much lower
that helps hopefully have one that will
work longer than the flu vaccine works
it's all speculation we just don't know
at this point one other bit of hopeful
vaccine news so we this is the Oxford
trial I've been telling you about the
there's a German company working with
Pfizer which has also started human
trials and they could potentially have
millions of vaccines ready in the 2020
calendar year now that could be November
it could be the end of December but they
are starting tests in the US next week
the idea is emergency use on the table
in the fall and if they get moving on
production soon before they even know
for sure that it'll work could have a
few million doses available
they say that twelve participants have
been vaccinated since the start of the
study on April 23rd no results yet many
things happening one thing I'm going to
address at the end of the show in the
voicemail segment is whether I would
want to be at the front of the line for
these vaccines I'll address that in a
little bit today's program is sponsored
in part by the galaxies series which is
a series of three
books written by a really great author I
thought and I would call the genre sort
of political science fiction I've really
enjoyed the books it looks at the future
it explores what could happen to Planet
Earth if we stay on our path
environmentally it deals with space
travel it takes a sort of deep dive into
political psychology and it's a really
intriguing sort of dystopian look at the
future the stories are told from a
perspective that I think people in the
audience would really appreciate and
there's a ton of really excellent
artwork also that accompanies the books
I read a lot of books in this genre and
I'll tell you these books are very well
written the plot the characters are
compelling if you're someone who likes
politics and sci-fi you'll really like
these books again it's the galaxy series
check it out for yourself for a limited
time we have a special deal set up where
my audience can get each book for just
99 cents go to david pakman.com slash
galaxy